à
à 2000 km de pékin comme d'amis sont
pyatt vêtus de noir surtout et parapluie
à la main des dizaines de milliers de
personnes ont bravé l'interdiction de
manifester pour ce mouvement pro
démocratie le 70e anniversaire de la
chine communiste est un jour de chagrin
et de deux le deuil de nos libertés de
notre droit de s'exprimer dit cette
jeune femme qui vient de piétiner au
passage la photo du président chinois
si je déteste le parti communiste de la
chine dit elle avant de rattraper la
grande marche qui grossit à vue d'oeil
pour l'instant les policiers sont
complètement absents du paysage
on soupçonne aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
cachés dans les centres d'achats dans
les magasins autour de nous en liant
gard et les bouches de métro
puis le cul de sac était inévitable et
la violence aussi
ces jeunes masqués désormais célèbre qui
n'ont peur de rien s'est faite aux
policiers
l'assaut est venue de parc d'un côté les
forces de l'ordre de l'autre des
manifestants enragés quillan 10 briques
et des cocktails molotov la ligne de
front et chaotique la police confirmera
plus tard ce que cette idée doit capter
sur le v un agent a bel et bien tiré à
balles réelles dans la poitrine de
manifestant de 18 ans c'est la première
fois qu'il est dans un état critique
les affrontements se sont transformées
en émeutes
les résidents des quartiers affectés
regard incrédule
même s'ils en ont déjà l'habitude il
disparaît désolé on se bat juste pour
notre liberté
qu'est ce que je peux répondre à sa
guise et soutenait ouais ouais ouais je
les soutiens ouais je soutiens si
c'était si tu étais pas aussi violent
registre elle quand la nuit tombe la
tension est à son plus haut
les immeubles du gouvernement dont
pommes sont la cible d'attaqués et des
commerces cros pékin aussi l'espoir d'un
dialogue et d'un dénouement à la crise
est de moins en moins envisageable
donc on s'attend ce que quelques heures
les choses se sont calmées on commence à
nettoyer comme on le fait tous les
week-ends mais ça sera certainement re
commencer d'ici quelques jours
il cite amaral correspond radio-canada
en com